[Music]
the be active workplace award recognizes
and celebrates outstanding initiatives
in the workplace encouraging employees
to be physically active
the 2021 recipient of the ward was
hungarian company idata kft specialized
in the development of gps tracking
software and hardware with most of its
employees working on the company's gps
tracking system day in and day out
mostly in front of their computers
promoting physical activity and
well-being has always been a priority
for idata kft
the company's sound mind in a sound body
program launched in 2016 provides
incentives to be active in two ways
individual sports activities and
community events on the individual level
employees are encouraged to collect
points according to a predefined scoring
system for countless sports activities
ranging from aerobic over yoga to
kayaking
friendly competitions are promoted
between employees and teams with awards
such as athlete of the month or most
sporty employee
this friendly competition increased
employee participation every year since
the launch of the program boasting a
current 84 participation rate
at the community level activities
involved not only employees but also
their friends and family with so-called
family day sporting events the last of
which welcomed over 180 participants
to round off its comprehensive approach
to well-being of the workplace idata kft
also offers its employees sessions with
two full-time psychologists as mental
and physical health go hand in hand half
of our colleagues started to sport part
of because our new sport program what we
started six years ago it is the most
important thing and the most important
benefit for us